У Анни Горчакової з Мінська вроджене пошкодження хребта.
У Німеччину вона приїхала з партнером з танців
Романом Усмановим і колегою Олесею Алехнович.
Сьогодні молоді люди з Білорусі випробують,
наскільки доступне для пересування візком
міське середовище в німецькому Бонні.
У центрі міста - знижені бордюри.
Підземних переходів лише зі сходами немає,
а наземні переходи обладнані світлофорами з датчиками.
На зупинці трамваю є не лише пандуси, але й
рельєфна розмітка для людей із вадами зору.
- У Німеччині я була багато разів, і нам
не траплялося місць, в які не можна заїхати на візку.
Якщо ви нам скажете, що такі місця існують, ми дуже здивуємося.
На батьківщині, в Білорусі, Анна та Олеся пересуваються виключно автівкою,
- Тому що насправді пересуватися містом, країною тільки так можливо.
- Навіть якщо це одна зупинка на транспорті, 600 метрів.
Я можу це подолати на машині, але без неї -
громадським транспортом або по вулиці - це нереально.
- Зараз намагаються в метро робити ліфти.
Вони їх роблять, але тут виявляється, що вони зламані.
Вони не знають, як з ними працювати.
Вони їх просто вимикають, блокують, і ти все одно не скористаєшся метро.
- А оці пандуси в метро в Мінську?
- Дві такі круті рейки, на яких ти просто вбиваєшся.
Це небезпечно для життя. І для себе, і для людини,
яка кинеться допомагати, теж небезпечно.
І ось під’їжджає трамвай.
- Куди? Куди?
Двері, в які мають входити пасажири на візках, не відчиняються.
Однак Анна і Олеся без проблем проїжджають у звичайні двері.
Тут немає спеціальних кріплень для людей на візках,
але Анна тримається за звичайні поручні.
- Небезпечніше стояти на гальмах. Він просто буде перекидатися.
А тут, якщо смикне, то лише відкотиться.
На зупинці трамвай під'їжджає впритул до платформи.
Вибратися з вагону Анні та Олесі вдається без сторонньої допомоги.
Парадокс, але за кордоном дівчата орієнтуються краще, ніж у Мінську,
адже їздити на громадському транспорті
вони можуть тільки за кордоном.
- Тепер я натискатиму?
- У Мінську так само, правда?
- Так, є, я здалеку бачила, що хтось щось натискав.
Але у мене дійсно не виходить гуляти.
- Чому?
- Бо яка ж це прогулянка? Ти вийшов - бах, бордюр,
гей, хоч хтось, допоможіть, усе, давай, затягли.
Знову трохи пройшов, знову, бах, бордюр.
- Тобто ви зовсім не гуляєте по Мінську?
- Ні.
- Перед тим, як піти гуляти, треба провести
велике дослідження: як пройти, як проїхати, де бордюр.
Зайти в гугл-карти, передивитися фотографії,
чи є там бордюри, сходинки. Подзвонити туди,
куди ти хочеш прийти, запитати, як у них із безбар’єркою.
Дівчата прямують до набережної Рейну.
У Бонні, як і в багатьох старих містах Німеччини, в центрі багато бруківки.
- Взагалі незручно. Візок, звичайно, їде, але це...
- Бруківка від бруківки різниться.
- Вона дрібненька, це краще. А коли більша, то взагалі біда.
Однак на підході до Рейну - перепона: круті сходинки.
Похилого з’їзду поблизу не видно.
- Тут є з’їзд для візків?
- Вам треба обійти навколо і там спуститися.
Виявляється, і в Німеччині не все так ідеально з безбар'єрним середовищем.
Об'їжджати занадто далеко, тому прогулянку біля Рейну доведеться скасувати.
Дівчата і Роман поспішають в спортивний комплекс на околиці міста,
де відбувається чемпіонат світу з танців на візках.
- Нам сюди? Ми заходимо? Ось в цей автобус?
Біжимо?
- Так, тут намальований візок.
Водій автобуса зобов'язаний вийти і відкинути пандус
для заїзду людини з інвалідністю, якщо та без супроводу.
Але цього разу Анні допоміг її друг Роман.
- У нас, до речі, теж такі є.
- Одиниці.
Анна відзначає, що і в Білорусі інфраструктура покращується.
- Повільно, але невпинно, рік за роком у нас в країні
з'являються пандуси. Місто Мінськ, безумовно, лідер у цій справі.
Я б сказала, що в центрі міста в багатьох будівлях є пандуси, знижені бордюри.
Але головне, що змінюється, - це ставлення людей.
Дуже сильні зміни. Не лише Білорусь, Росія, власне, країни пострадянського простору.
Зараз усі розуміють, що людині з інвалідністю потрібна допомога,
хоча б початкова допомога, щоб вона могла самостійно жити.
Тобто не ставлення: давайте ми зараз пожаліємо цю людину
і будемо жаліти її все життя, всім її забезпечимо, і нехай вона тупо сидить удома.
А вже розуміють, що людині з інвалідністю потрібно вчитися,
потрібно працювати, що вона теж хоче одружуватися, народжувати дітей.
Проїзд у громадському транспорті для людей, які
мають посвідчення про важкий ступінь інвалідності, в Німеччині безкоштовний.
- Відчуття таке, що ти в будь-якій точці висадився
і катайся по всій Німеччині скільки завгодно.
Електричкою, автобусом, трамвайчиком.
Відчуття свободи реальне.
У нас в країні цього немає. Але в мене немає негативних емоцій з цього приводу.
Напевно, тому, що в принципі я народилася з інвалідністю,
народилася паралізованою, і я звикла, що все моє життя - певне подолання.
Анна - чотириразова чемпіонка світу
та Європи з танців на візках.
У Бонн вона приїхала, щоб укотре відстояти звання найкращої.
- Хвилюєтеся?
- Так, завжди.
Разом із партнером Романом вони демонструють
різні танці зі стандартної програми:
повільний вальс,
віденський вальс,
фокстрот,
квікстеп
та улюблений танець Анни - танго.
Усього пара виконала цього дня 20 танцювальних номерів.
Такий марафон і людині без обмежених фізичних можливостей витримати складно,
але Анна і Роман тримаються на висоті і виходять у фінал.
Навіть те, що через невдалий маневр суперників
Анна впала з візка, здається, її анітрохи не знітило.
У результаті Анна і Роман посіли друге місце.
Для Анни це стимул наступного року
ще старанніше тренуватися, щоб  повернути титул.